what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice evaluating exponents
of decimals so let's say that I have 0.2
to the third power pause this video see
if you can figure out what that is going
to be well this would just mean if I
take something to the third power that
means I take 3 of that number and I
multiply them together so that's 0.2
times 0.2 times 0.2 well what is this
going to be equal to well if I take is
0.2 times 0.2 that is going to be 0.04
one way to think about it
2 times 2 is 4 and then I have one
number behind the decimal to the right
of the decimal here I have another digit
to the right of the decimal right over
here so my product is going to have two
digits to the right of the decimal so
it'd be 0.04 and then if I were to
multiply that times 0.2 so if I were to
multiply that together what is that
going to be equal to well 4 times 2 is
equal to 8 and now I have one two three
numbers to the right of the decimal
point so my product is going to have one
two three numbers to the right of the
decimal point so now that we've had a
little bit of practice with that let's
do another example so let's say that I
were to ask you what is 0.9 squared
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right well this is just going to be
0.9 times 0.9 and what's that going to
be equal to well you could just say 9
times 9 is going to be equal to 81 and
so let's see in the two numbers that i'm
multiplying i have a total of one two
numbers or two digits to the right of
the decimal point so my answer is going
to have one two digits to the right of
the decimal point so I put the decimal
right over there and I'll put the zero
so zero point eight one another way to
think about it is nine
tense of 9/10 is 81 hundredths but there
you go
using exponents or or taking exponents
of decimals it's the same as when we're
taking it of integers it's just in this
case you just have to do a little bit of
a decimal multiplication